the third point
that's very important
is that
none of this is new
um at least not as new as it may seem
the roots of gen of modern gender
ideology can be traced all the way back
to the 19th century in fact arguably
even earlier than that
but it really began to take its current
shape in the mid 20th century thanks to
the work of two hideously evil crackpots
named alfred kinsey and john money
these are names that everybody should
know and few people do
in the interest of time i'll focus on
john money for just a moment it's worth
looking into alfred kinsey though we
talk about him in the film a little bit
but an even deeper dive is worthwhile if
you do in fact do that make sure to have
a vomit bucket handy
as for john money he was a prominent
psychologist and sexologist and uh one
of the one of the early pioneers of the
gender theories that are currently
taught in grade schools and universities
he was among the first to take the word
gender
out of the realm of of grammar
and apply it to people
because until him you know we never said
that people have a gender
well people have a sex and gender is
words have gender
but he said no no no people have gender
and sex
and he coined that he also coined the
terms gender role gender identity and
sexual orientation
suffice it to say he was an extremely
influential man and anybody who
propagates left-wing gender theory today
is repeating at least some of the ideas
of john money whether they know it or
not and most of them do not know it
that fat that fact i think ought to
trouble gender theory proponents because
john money was among other things
a fraud and an abuser and a pedophile
jumping to 1965 the birth of twins bruce
and brian reimer
the boys are born healthy except for a
condition called phimosis which affects
the foreskin and it was decided
incorrectly it turns out that the best
way to treat the condition was
circumcision
but bruce's procedure went horribly
wrong as penis was essentially burned
off
after several months of grasping for
answers bruce's parents eventually
decided to take him to johns hopkins in
baltimore to see the renowned
gender
surgeon dr john money
and the good doctor eager to prove the
legitimacy of his theory that gender is
a product of environment and culture
recommended that bruce undergo sex
reassignment surgery
so before the age of of two the deed had
been done his testicles were removed
some crude approximation of female
genitalia was formed and um money
instructed his parents to raise him as a
girl and said that well this will work
perfectly because
gender is a social construct so create a
social construct of femininity for him
and he will be a her and that will be it
happily ever after
well not so
the rhymer parents tried to follow
money's advice but they found that bruce
was still bruce even if they called him
brenda
it did everything in their power to
preserve his fragile and false female
identity
gender is a construct they were told
why should a boy raised as a girl still
have boyish tendencies
still ultimately money was convinced
that his project had been a smashing
success and he bragged of his triumphs
in many published works
but it was not a success
the female identity never took hold for
bruce he was confused and miserable and
on the verge of suicide
until as a teen his mother finally told
him the truth
bruce chose immediately to transition
back to a boy taking the name of david
uh he underwent another reassignment
surgery this time to try and reclaim his
true self
and he felt better for a time but
neither his brother nor himself lived
happily ever after
um ultimately they both ended up
committing suicide
now their deaths go down in history as
suicides but they were both effectively
murdered by john money who's the father
of modern
gender theory
and that's the birth of gender ideology
as we know it today it was born
in abuse and despair and death
and that is what it has reaped ever
since